NBC's Savannah Guthrie interviewed Nick
salmon the reluctant face of the
Covington controversy first up some
people some people see is a young kid
with a smirk on his face there's that
some people again one day I'd like to
meet some people some say it Savannah
Guthrie then came Nathan Phillips claim
of a build the wall chance that
apparently no one else heard did anyone
say build the wall I never heard anyone
say build the wall and I don't think
I've seen it in any videos after a
review of the videos NBC News could not
hear anyone shouting that hot-button
phrase yeah so no one chanted it but
what if they did some say we're letting
liberal fascists decide what can't be
said in public the black Israelites said
things that we can't repeat here but
it's build the wall that matters most
it's a hot-button issue some say which
is media for let's trash you then came
back do you think if you weren't wearing
that hat this might not have happened or
it might have been different that's
possible but I would have to assume what
mr. Phillips was thinking and I'd rather
let him speak for why he came up to us
sound familiar
you go out wearing that clearly you're
asking for it because you're just a
victim of your own choices and actions
you neglect that they were mainly
victims of their own choices and actions
shouldn't we discuss that wonder if the
hats had anything to do with your muted
response imagine saying that about a
feminist protester and her clothes funny
how the media who claimed their speech
is always under threats because a Trump
are now dictating what words and
clothing are forbidden then they blame
the victim he'll now standing is even
hateful there's something aggressive
about standing there standing your
ground you both stood your ground
and it was like a staredown what do you
think of that now when you think about
that moment I would say mr. folks had
his right to come up to me I had my
right to stay there I don't know maybe
standing is the only thing to do when a
stranger beats his drum in your face but
then Guthrie questioned why the teens
would be scared of male adult strangers
aggressively taunting them did you feel
threatened at all I definitely felt
threatened there were more of you than
them but you felt like they were
stronger they were a group adults and I
wasn't sure what was gonna happen next
okay so get this when a team is standing
quietly somehow that's threatening but
what four crackpots threaten you
that's just good-natured fun meanwhile
the Washington Post whines that the
right has seized on their screw-up so
after pushing this smear they're now
blaming others for getting caught some
might say the outcry prevented the press
from doing far worse so watching the
media analyze this mess I feel like I'm
watching a murderer doing an autopsy on
his own victim hmm it must be suicide
they declare well some say they suck all
right Jesse so we heard from the kid
isn't it time that we see Nathan up
there answering some questions Jess I
think Nathan needs to go get the
Savannah treatment but this is the thing
he won't be able to answer her questions
I just did a little investigation
because the media won't and Nathan Phil
it's fresh off of this confrontation
with the student disrupted and in
tempted to disrupt the mass at DC's
National Shrine he tried with a bunch of
people 20 of them to go bang drums
invade the National Shrine during Mass
on this day and they had to have
security block him and lock the doors as
he attempted to gain entry it's also
come to our attention this guy never
served in Vietnam he was a Marine but a
lot of reports are saying he went AWOL
four times and actually had to be put in
the Brig but he's on video saying when
he returned from Vietnam he was called a
baby killer and spit on you never went
to
Vietnam so Philips also gave an
interview and no one's even talked about
this he was talking about what he was
thinking this guy Phillips said these
white students were in the process of
attacking the black individuals didn't
happen they were quote beasts preying on
the black individuals and he called the
students racists and he said the looks
on the kids faces were similar to the
faces during lynchings in the south now
this guy's stories change seven times
the fact that the media believed this
guy without checking anything what else
is the media being told and just running
with mm-hmm
how do we know it fit their assumptions
I mean the thing what kills me Jed is
the say it the idea like if you're
wearing something you had it coming
we've learned that that's not what you
say to people the nerve to say that to a
kids wearing a woman oh you were wearing
that that's a lie no you're wearing a
skirt like that you deserve it I mean
it's crazy and they're counting on see
you just did that research but they're
counting on no one doing that or you do
it but it doesn't get propagate it
doesn't get sent out all they need is
that initial clip and the judgments to
be made now imagine if you went out and
you were at a March and you had a you
were a kid and you had a bunch of adults
screaming at you shouting horrific
things I give I'm still trying to figure
out what this kid did wrong I see he
smirked I see that I see maybe he had a
little bit he was confused he didn't
know what's going on he didn't assault
anybody he didn't even shout back how
many people can say that as a teenager
their first instinct wouldn't have been
to say something back to say no you're
this or they didn't even do that these
kids were on their best behavior frankly
given what was going on if you watch the
before and after and I can't believe
that we're still talking about a smirk
from a kid because he had a maggot hat
on if he didn't have a mag ahead and
that was not a pro-life protest this
would not be a story know when and you
know Dana I well I'd the lesson I
learned I'm never ever looking at a
viral video again again because I it is
actually so funny that it's called viral
because it's contagious pernicious and
it makes you sexy sick yes it does make
you sick you think
remember and back in the day before the
internet's early fifties this would not
have been a national story or
international story at all it would have
been a local DC story
maybe maybe on the Nationals made me on
the national news but unlikely to have
ever gone beyond that and so now these
kids are having to go on the Today Show
which is quite intimidating and that's
not the savannahs intimidating but look
like you're basically on your own
they're in a room here's 17 years old 15
years without however old he is and what
I read was that the left and the right
was mad at Savannah Guthrie after this
interview I'm not sure why the left
would be mad yeah I don't know I I have
to say one I wouldn't have been
performed as well as that kid did in an
event like that that's like his first
time on TV I think I don't know his
facial expression was frozen he looked
like he's terrified I don't know now
clearly they hired a PR firm yeah to
represent how dare they I know him and
all that but I just got to say to you
guys I don't understand how you've made
this young man into some you know victim
here it's clearly not what you're saying
is let's blame the media and you and I
agreed yesterday by the way the social
media platform that spread this yeah we
don't even know who they are where
they're from and we know who the
Washington Post is no no hang on and
they have intentionally pushed out
polarizing type videos intended to
stress the people who push them are
always liberal media let me let it
finish wanna control breathe in breathe
in stream media had ignored this story
and I think Dana's right I don't think
the local section of Washington Post
would have covered this yeah but if the
mainstream media had ignored the fact
that the right and left picked up on
this the left and they would say oh my
gosh why is the mainstream media
ignoring this big story but in fact let
me tell you tomorrow night I'm gonna go
watch a basketball game tomorrow night
the black Israelites will be standing
there and they'll be saying rude things
to me my wife they say them everybody
but you had coming but people don't
stand there and engage and then is the
first time they ever saw
waiting to go home let me just say those
kids stand there and you said he says oh
well I'm just standing here
no he's staring down that made staring
up and down - Drummond ah you got four
or five black Israelites you got up
there harmless just loads of these kids
and suddenly oh they are feeling so
threatened you hadn't told Legion
children this is ridiculous and then you
we got about things like blackface and
basketball games if you want to bring up
though you want to talk about that we
can talk about what that means in
another block they have these events
where they go black they go white they
go different colors
yeah so there was a racial thing okay
we'll go to that